los odiputados han pedido También en
esta resolución que se cambie la
legislación europea para que la Unión
Europea considere no solo las
organizaciones de las personas
terroristas también a los Estados a la
práctica una medida de este tipo sería
convertir a Rusia en un estado varias en
que la Unión Europea debería cortar
lazos diplomáticos y económicos algo muy
difícil de poder aplicar a la práctica
de hecho ningún país del mundo ha
llegado tan lejos ha habido resoluciones
no vinculantes en Estados Unidos como
por ejemplo en el senado y en el
congreso pero hasta ahora el secretario
de estado norteamericano Anthony blinken
lo ha rechazado y también votaciones No
vinculantes en parlamentos Como por
ejemplo de los países bálticos o de
Polonia